[Music]
it was famously John peels favorite
record of all time two and a half
minutes of surging pop punk two fingers
held up to parents teachers and anyone
else over the age of twenty
chicks man
[Music]
the undertones classic is a charged
anthem from a different time one before
freedom of movement across Europe older
wiser the band's former lead singers
memories of that time are not all boozy
I actually do come from a generation and
I physically have watched look on their
hands and knees at the back of a stage
after a gig picking up broken drumsticks
and Curly not guitar strings into little
packets because the rules where if you
said in the paperwork you took 400
drumsticks out of the country you better
bring back 400 drumsticks even if
they're all broken
I have personally stood and watched our
road crew steaming with fury whilst some
belligerent bureaucrat made them unload
and 40-foot Arctic trailer something too
kind
the number of speakers do we really want
to go back to that the end of freedom of
movement threatened by brexit is along
with intellectual property the key
concern of many working in the UK's
creative industries we are phenomenally
good at this thing about being creative
and that includes writing songs making
music performing making movies creating
games and software and doing all kinds
of things brags it has an enormous
danger to actually dismantle one of the
most successful industries in this
country and indeed the world and so the
industry is on maneuvers striking a
rather discordant note that haven't been
terribly many high profile rock and
rollers singing Breck's its praises
other closeted brexit ears out there in
the creative industries well we did a
survey recently of musicians and
composers and a whole bunch of people in
the industry and we found that only two
percent felt that brexit would be a
positive from their point of view I have
to tell you that we've not yet found
those two percent and and if you find
them before us please letters and no
more than fifty percent as you would
imagine said that they were hugely
concerned that brexit would have a
negative impact and I think that does
reflect some of these challenges and
fears that people have about how
difficult it will be once Britain leaves
the like many other areas of the UK
economy its clarity as to transition as
to our end trading relationship that the
music business is demanding as their
time pressure on the situation is
regards to the creative industries I
mean do you when do you need to know
over a year away and I suppose
still none the wiser really brexit is
probably the most high-profile public
and complex game of multi-dimensional
chess that we've seen it's a very public
negotiation we've just got to ensure
that the music industry makes its voice
loud and clear
in terms of the impact that brexit could
have and that's one that we'll continue
to do and of course it's not ads or
Adele or any other musician identifiable
by the first name that has most to lose
from brexit it's those who make a living
gig to Gig not at Wembley but in smaller
venues like the jw3 Community Center
Emily Barca is a singer/songwriter
recently returned from a month-long tour
in Europe I'm very concerned about how
expensive visas would potentially be for
each territory as well as the
bureaucracy involved in how long it
would take so I recently got my first
u.s. working visa and it cost me a
fortune a small fortune and it was
relatively late notice the tour that I
was offered so I had to pay for a
fast-track visa which was an additional
huge sum of money and then there was no
guarantee that I would get it so that
really concerns me how much time it
would take to put visas together for
one-off opportunities which often come
up such as festivals where you go over
and you do one show and then you fly
back do you think this governor and
previous governments do you think they
recognize just how important the
creative industries are to our economy I
think often not enough and I think music
accounts for such a is such a huge
British export and it's so important and
so I think that they should value it
[Music]
despite British artists literally
providing the site and track to our
lives you'd be forgiven for thinking the
music industry wasn't his greater
priority in these brexit associations as
farming Fisheries Policy the Northern
Irish border there what could be more
powerful than a musician with a
grievance
it is perhaps almost as surprising as
the sight of a middle-aged bloke image
sits at a gig but the scale the
contribution to our economy made by the
creative industries truly is
extraordinary in 2016 9 million pounds
were generated every era that's fifty
four billion pounds in just one year and
of course
musicians don't tend to our problems
when it comes to making themselves now
and certainly the industry is hopeful
that their concerns are being listened
to one of the true UK success stories
growing year after year despite these
straight and financial times when there
are brexit song is written well
Britain's musicians be chopping out the
power chords or end up singing the blues
[Music]
[Applause]